enia la maison qui on va le faire tomber
ces [ __ ] mur est abondée blindés ravi
ouais on va bien s'occuper de toi
qu'est-ce qu'il allait me tuer le maire
et une voiture qui viennent se garer sur
le parking
c'est juste le vj folio il doit avoir
son téléphone
attendez je crois qu'il en est une autre
ah non c'est sa [ __ ]
amusez-vous les vigiles vous aimez bien
tard les cowboys 1 allée là tôt mais
j'imagine même pas de quoi il est
capable
marie va faire une connerie ancien chef
de guerre africains sont nommés walter
de sanguinet visite mc comme responsable
sécurité quant au magasin je vais vous
envoyer jouer les bonhommes allah ya
plus personne à moi mon époque on mac os
lion sous dépôt des bronchites et
lissage on n'écoutait pas du rap de
[ __ ]
c'est construit c'était pas top
je veux jouer en moi je veux jouer on va
jouer et je peux pas aller lui parler
dans votre langue et pitt matt écouter
toi c'est sûr je suis là où l'avenir on
tue dix mois ça c'est le blanc seing
ils veulent nous diviser son fils
michael j'ai toujours parlé comme ça
on va se retrouver en taule sont
vraiment en prison
24 une perruque qui vont m'appeler samir
a défoncé monkey plus